hey Scotty little soldiers welcome to  the Christmas party I hope you guys got  some rest for tonight's excitement I  hear from Sharpie and George there are  five villains and you guys need to stop  from ruining Christmas so use your  teamwork your brains and your born to  make sure that you do exactly that find  them and don't let them ruin Christmas  okay  at the same time Christmas is a time  when we miss our loved ones really  really badly and that's okay but at the  same time  it can be possible to feel guilty for  having fun without our parents but I am  here to assure you that our parents  always want us to have fun okay so don't  feel guilty you're allowed to have the  best time ever especially with this kind  of little soldiers community so go out  there have the best time and